alain juppé intervient dans la sphère
des sans papiers il reprend le dossier
en main et demande l'avis du conseil
d'état plus de 5000 personnes
manifestent en faveur des africains de
l'église saint-bernard à part la
belgique s'apprête à rendre hommage aux
enfants tués par marc dutroux la fin de
la trêve des attentats officialisé en
corse
notre enquête sur le bilan de la saison
touristique est un médicament sous
surveillance le roaccutane un traitement
contre l'acné
madame monsieur bonsoir alain juppé a
donc repris en main le dossier des sans
papiers de l'église saint bernard à
paris à l'issue d'un comité
interministériel qui a réuni pendant
près d'une heure et demie neuf ministres
à matignon les services d'alain juppé
ont rappelé la politique du premier
ministre en matière d'immigration une
politique de fermeté même si
l'application des lois doit tenir compte
des situations particulier un peu plus
tard jean lui devrait recevait le porte
parole des sans papiers il faisait
savoir qu'il saisissait le conseil
d'état pour qu'il examine les conditions
d'application des lois pasqua
marie pierre farkas et fille du jeu cela
en d'urgence à matignon
neuf ministres rappeler à la hâte pour
évaluer la situation des africains sans
papiers comme le dit laconiquement le
communiqué qui émane des services du
premier ministre un commentaire à 15h30
mais une ébauche de solution après une
heure de discussion
le gouvernement vient de saisir le
conseil d'état pour lui demander son
avis sur l'interprétation qu'on peut
donner aux lois pasqua
une décision que le ministre de
l'intégration est le seul à bien vouloir
commenter à chaud des lois de la
république ont été votés par l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
elle s'applique pour autant fils doit y
avoir fermeté de la part du gouvernement
le gouvernement aussi du caire et le
gouvernement on veut régler en toute
humanité
un certain nombre de cases individuelles
qui peuvent se présenter on n'a jamais
dit que sur les sans papiers de l'église
saint bernard 54 caps avaient d'ores et
déjà été réglée il peut y avoir des
examens encore d'une manière attentive
de ces cas qui relèvent de l'humanité
mais pour autant on ne peut pas donner
un signal aux autres pays européens
ou un africain ou du monde en disant
venez en france
séjourner illégalement en france pendant
quelques mois et ensuite où quelques
années et ensuite vous savez bien
entendu accepté comme des étrangers en
séjour dieu de manière légale avant
notre pays ça c'est pas possible
même discours de jean louis debré au
porte parole des sans papiers qui l'a
reçu à 17 heures au ministère de
l'intérieur et les avis que le conseil
d'état ait saisi vous faire une autre
interprétation des lois alors il attend
la décision du conseil d'état et agira
en fonction des résultats
une journée d'activités ministériel
intense la première rencontre du
ministre de l'intérieur et des
sans-papiers plus la vie sollicité du
conseil d'état à l'évidence le
gouvernement à chercher aujourd'hui à
reprendre l'initiative et cet avis du
conseil d'état devrait être délivré
d'ici la fin de la semaine pendant ces
consultations la mobilisation à gauche
poursuivent et par une manifestation
entre la place de république et l'église
st bernard près de 5000 personnes
manifester sur place
barry fournioux et françoise david
alors même où le porte parole des sans
papiers de l'église saint-bernard été
reçus par le ministère de l'intérieur on
se rassembler place de la république
était venu ceux qui soutiennent le
combat les 300 africains en quête de
régularisation de leur situation
administrative
nombre d'entre eux étaient sensibles à
ce qu'ils pensaient peut-être une
avancée sensible dans le règlement de
cette affaire
peut-être on a gagné il faut gagner
ils ont gagné tout ce vous méprise est
un peu plus les méprisait gouvernement
il pourra pas s'arrêter là et je pense
que tout geste aujourd'hui apte à
prendre position
je crois qu'il faut rester très
mobilisés pour que effectivement on
prenne en compte et compte que s'engage
une négociation la mobilisation qui est
un effet significatif militants des
partis de gauche sans doute l'art
d'aimer asmani terre avaient répondu
présent à l'appel du collectif des sans
papiers l'ambiance musicale à pully se
ressentait du changement d'attitude du
gouvernement à l'église saint-bernard
par ailleurs on avait aussi accueilli
dans l'après-midi à nouveau le gréviste
de la faim dont l'état de santé avait
dit hier nécessité une hospitalisation
de moi de toute façon je peux compter
que l'on dise qu'on vous ait fait pas le
studio l'appel des sous comme toulouse
ou sac et ice et neuf camarades sont
toujours déterminés à poursuivre leur
mouvement et à propos de cette affaire
noter ce sondage c'est ça que publiera
le journal le parisien demain selon ce
sondage un français sur deux soutiens
les sans papiers de l'église
saint-bernard alors que 30% leur sont
hostiles
56 % souhaitent également que le
gouvernement ouvre des négociations pour
régler le problème contre 36% qui sont
opposés avec nous en direct de l'église
saint-bernard boubacar diop bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes donc le porte parole
où l'un des porte parole des sans
papiers de saint-bernard vous avez vu
monsieur debré cet après midi est-ce que
les propositions de monsieur debré vous
on s'est il satisfait pas du tout
nous ne sommes pas du tout satisfaits
d'autant plus qu' on a souligné
néanmoins temouchent remise intérieure
l'incohérence de ses propos depuis le 26
juin dernier
alors pour être clair il faut préciser
que monsieur debré a priori vous a dit
que tous les sans-papiers de saint père
ne serait pas régularisé sait cela mais
nous souhaitons simplement une chose qui
est plus complète c'est que dans le dans
les vins qui ont intégré chez nous il y
a des parents d'enfants français et à
des parents d'enfants nés en france si
elle est célibataire
là il nous dit qu'il ne va pas
régulariser les célibataires ou quelle
raison on est en démocratie ch'ti il a
appliqué une décision plus longs qu'à
cibler l'ensemble des sans-papiers qui
sont mais est-ce que vous êtes presque
il y est un examen au cas par cas de
chacun d'entre vous dans l'église et que
dans fonctions cet examen les résultats
ne soient pas aussi favorable pour les
uns et pour les autres
j'ai toujours dit que l'examen des
dossiers cas par cas est en cours pour
la nuit parce que même dans le cadre du
duc de la comptabilité on est obligé de
regarder le dossier d'une personne donc
le cas par cas c'était et les
écoulements la seule chose qui compte
c'est que nous nous entendons traité à
part du moment où une décision fois
quelqu'un qui est dans la même situation
que l'autre mais deux doivent être en
même temps régler mais avec un
raisonnement comme celui là monsieur
juppé rappelait encore aujourd'hui en
tout cas les services de matignon que si
on régulariser tous les sans-papiers de
saint bernard il faudrait régulariser
tous les sans papiers en france le loup
lapointe et la question parce que je
crois que monsieur juppé ses services
rappeler cet après midi que dans sa
politique de fermeté contre
l'immigration si on régulariser tous les
sans-papiers de saint bernard il
faudrait régulariser tout le monde
c'est absolument faux le travail des
experts vraiment cheap et même s'ils en
avaient la raison et nous ce g2 dernier
l'a bien compris même si on égalise et
les trois sans-papiers des saint-bernard
et ne serait pas fait un appel d'air
combien de civils et donc la situation
ne se pose même pas c'est vrai qu'il ya
un progrès le programme
j'ai un problème de politique d'ensemble
d'une d'émulation et ça il faut le
revoir
même quand on égalerait redescend de 300
personnes même si des propositions
concrètes sont faites à bon nombre
d'entre vous en vue d'une régularisation
vous n'allez pas céder vous allez rester
unis non le problème qui se pose
actuellement c'est la réouverture des
négociations sur la base des 10 critères
que nous avons toujours proposé et
ensuite un mois la corse et les
exclusions aidé à ce propos le maintien
ne se prononce pas pour un moratoire
alors qu'ils demandent l'avis du conseil
d'état et en même temps on dit que
quelle que soit la décision du conseil
d'état
moi ça ne règle elle ne devrait pas
l'aider ce qui est cohérent alors une
dernière question monsieur debré ce soir
estime que cette affaire de
saint-bernard ferait partie d'une
stratégie politique pour faire
disparaître les lois de la république
vous avez l'impression de faire partie
d'une espèce de complot comme ça qui
tendrait à s'en prendre généralement ou
doit conduire les allemands qu'il y ait
un mousseux de l'aubier accompli que
quand les lois qui sont faites pour être
appliquées aux numériques qu'elles aient
des citations des manques dramatique
pour le point d'échangé on peut les
réformés et pourquoi pas les a plongés
mais le problème ne se situe pas en ce
moment dans cette région ce que nous
demandons c'est que à aux sans-papiers
saint bénin soit appliqué les mêmes
décisions qui ont été prises le 26 juin
on vous aura compris merci boubacar diop
et je rappelle que vous êtes donc l'un
des porte parole des sans papiers de
saint bernard en corse le secrétaire
général de l' concoules françois orsoni
annonce à mots couverts la fin de la
trêve la consulter la vitrine légale du
flnc canal historique
cette déclaration intervient alors que
de nouveaux attentats ont secoué l'île
la nuit dernière notamment à porto
vecchio contre les locaux de la dde la
direction départementale de l'équipement
et contre ceux de la sncm la société
nationale corse méditerranée
la belgique s'apprête à rendre un
hommage national à julie et mélissa les
deux fillettes de 8 ans morte de faim
chez marc dutroux
leurs obsèques auront lieu demain près
de cent mille personnes sont attendues à
la basilique saint martin de liège
pendant ce temps là la polémique fait
rage en belgique sur le rôle de la
justice depuis que l'on a découvert
qu'un rapport de police l'avait alerté à
plusieurs reprises sur les projets
criminels de marc dutroux mathieu chez
et maryse et chats
l'adieu à mélissa et à julie aura lieu
ici dans cette église
déjà les couronnes de fleurs recouvre
peu à peu les dates de pierre
transportés par des camions venant de
toute la belgique au funérarium
les portes se refermeront bientôt mais
la foule est encore là alors que le père
de julie s'attarde dans un couloir pour
régler les derniers préparatifs
demain la population sera une nouvelle
fois présente un réconfort pour les
parents ça nous fait plaisir dans ce
drame que tout le monde est sensible et
blessés et puis l'autre qualificative
par rapport à nos fiches limitera son
plaisir et ça nous aide encore ces jours
ci à titre lors de la messe le curé un
proche de la famille reviendra sur ces
longs mois de souffrance c'est dur à
vivre moi comme de mer comme d'ailleurs
pas seulement de mettre tout ce que nous
vivons tous et aussi et puis depuis 14
ans d'amour je me permettrai de le dire
demain dans la célébration que ces
quatorze mois c'est vraiment 14 stations
du calvaire
une cérémonie qui se déroulera sur fond
de polémique
hier la presse a en effet rendu public
certains documents des enquêteurs
chargés des disparitions en belgique
sur l'un d'eux datant de 1993 on peut
ainsi dire à propos de marc dutroux
ils nous avaient été signalés que
dutroux était occupé à faire des travaux
dans les caves d'une de ses maisons pour
y loger des enfants en attente d'être
expédiées à l'étranger
alors pourquoi marc dutroux n'at-il pas
été arrêté plus tôt malgré ses
nombreuses perquisitions pour les
familles c'est l'incompréhension a
depuis décidé depuis la découverte des
corps du génie ça tout ce que nous avons
clamé pendant 14 mois était pratiquement
tous étaient exactes donc maintenant
c'est tout la justice belge à
s'expliquer
et je pense que dans les semaines qui
vont suivre nous allons demander des
comptes et un je crois beaucoup de
choses qui vont se faire
voilà plus d'un an que julie et mélissa
font partie du quotidien de la
population belge
leur disparition les recherches et la
découverte des corps ont été vécus ici
comme un drame national
on attend demain plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes et il faut
remonter au décès du roi baudouin pour
ressentir une telle émotion et pour ses
obsèques les familles de julie et de
milices à en demander à ce que le roi
des belges albert ii ne soient pas
représentés officiellement aux
funérailles
sur le terrain les autorités se
mobilisent pour recueillir le moindre
renseignement une cellule spéciale a
même été constitué à la gendarmerie
fallait rire mythe et marie pierre
cassignard derrière ses grilles et ses
briques rouges
l'état major de la gendarmerie pour
toute la belgique depuis deux jours elle
abrite une toute nouvelle cellule une
cellule spéciale gendarmerie bonjour et
elle avait l'air de connaître l'individu
puisqu'elles sont montés facilement à
bord
vous avez une ressemblance une
ressemblance avec les quatre suspects
arrêtés dans la sphère de la belgique à
l'initiative des gendarmes
un numéro vert pour toutes les bonnes
volontés qui voudraient bien faire
avancer l'enquêté
une fois qu on connaissait c'est super
on a dit bon il faut re de nouveau aller
vers la grande publique parce que
peut-être encore des informations sûres
nous manquons et voilà c'est cela qu'on
a instauré ce cheminot exactions et des
informations les belges en donne une
voiture suspecte par sin maison bizarre
par là un homme au comportement étrange
ailleurs même si tous c'est évident
n'est pas fiable
tout le monde connaissait du trot tout
le monde était voisin avec le liège mons
a trafiqué avec ni aux antilles on se
connaissait en fait on se rend compte
qu'en posant des questions en fait les
gens finissent par diva se mêler les
pinceaux en fait on voit bien qu'il ya
quand même de l'invention que je pense
que toi un peu
un peu craintifs par rapport à leurs
enfants dit maintenant qu on approche le
prochain enfant ou directement et très
fort nous avertissent 1500 appels en
deux jours dix pour cent de ces
informations sont cependant jugées
exploitables
après l'émotion après les critiques
aussi les enquêteurs se sont donné cette
fois tous les moyens pour réussir les
autorités d'interpol faisait savoir hier
que deux jeunes filles enlevées il ya un
an par marc dutroux serait peut-être
toujours vivante
interpol c'est cette toile d'araignée
qui relie la plupart des polices du
monde un réseau d'information basé à
lyon marie pierre samitier et nathalie
gallet ici sont centralisées les
informations des 176 bureau d'interpol
dans le monde entier signalez très
précisément 400 p deux fils font l'objet
de renseignements car ils sont
susceptibles de commettre à nouveau des
actes sexuels sur des enfants
les réseaux auxquels ils appartiennent
sont partout une véritable toile
d'araignée car les pédophiles ont pour
principe de se contacter directement
je crois qu'ils sont très méfiants donc
en fait ils partagent les informations
mais avec des gens où ils sont
convaincus qu'ils s'y cache le même
intérêt dont chaque réseau les
pédophiles se connaissent bien entre eux
c'est un monde clos qui travaille avec
minutie ce pédophile a par exemple tout
un fichier informatisé où sont
sélectionnés les enfants avec leur
adresse et leur spécificité
ils ont la fâcheuse manie d'enregistrer
leur axe sous forme de vidéos de photos
ou même décrit où il raconte tout ce
qu'ils font chaque pédophiles a ses
préférences et donc se retrouve dans
tout un système pour échanger les
documents c'est prouve aussi la
nécessité de les échanger avec des
personnes qui éprouvent les mêmes
penchants sexuels que donc
automatiquement
ceci aboutit à des correspondances des
gemmes pas de m'envoyer le terme réseau
parce que c'est c'est plus des cercles
ça commence par des cercles et par la
suite pour certains ça devient beaucoup
plus organisé beaucoup plus phase
internationale est donc bon
automatiquement on a on en vient à
utiliser le terme réseau 396 enfants
disparus la plupart occidentaux sont
donc signalé ici dans les bureaux
d'interpol
un nombre qui va sans doute augmenter
avec le trafic inquiétant des anciens
il est sans compter ceux qu'on ne
signale même pas en asie en afrique ou
en amérique du sud
en angleterre la sphère de charleroi
mobilisent à nouveau les associations de
lutte contre la pédophilie
on se souvient de la sphère de la maison
de l'horreur à gloucester dans laquelle
200 enfants avaient été victimes de
violences sexuelles
les associations espèrent maintenant
obtenir un renforcement de la
législation jacques cardoze bradford
l'une des villes les plus touchées par
la prostitution enfantine ici en
grande-bretagne ce qui encourage ces
jeunes filles de moins de 16 ans à se
prostituer sont passibles d'une peine de
prison de sept ans ce n'est pas assez
répondent les sept associations
spécialisées dans la protection de
l'enfance depuis trois ans le collectif
qui regroupe ces ong réclament un
renforcement des lois qu'ils pourraient
enfin obtenir d'ici décembre prochain
match où il faudra semblait beaucoup
plus d'informations et de données
pour l'instant on a seulement une petite
idée du nombre d'enfants qui se
prostituent c'est en partie à cause de
la nature de l'activité cash est illégal
et donc il est difficile de savoir
vraiment les choses dans son rapport
rendu public cette semaine l'association
fait état d'un nombre croissant
d'enfants abusés sexuellement
pourtant ici les contacts sont nombreux
avec les mineurs victimes de la
pédophilie à l'étranger les un contact
ne signifie pas pour autant la fin du
calvaire commence bien entendu les
enfants les plus vulnérables sont ceux
qui sont baladés d'un établissement à un
autre qui n'ont plus de lien avec leur
famille ont suivi ce sont ceux qui ont
le plus de risques d'être confronté à la
prostitution
la grande-bretagne sensibiliser à la
pédophilie parce qu'elle aussi a connu
l'horreur en 93 rose marie et frédéric
ouest avaient été arrêtés reconnus
coupables de plusieurs meurtres mais au
cours du procès on apprenait que 200
mineurs avaient été abusées sexuellement
dans cette chambre sordide
en l'espace de 20 ans des similitudes
avec les derniers événements à tel point
que le policier britannique chargée de
cette enquête est arrivé hier soir en
belgique
en france un incendie dans un hôtel de
clermont ferrand a fait quatre morts et
14 blessés la nuit dernière
l'hôtel était vétuste et dépourvu
d'issues de secours benoît gadret et
jean claude martin du petit at-elle il
ne reste plus que des murs calcinés
les 19 chambres du savoie ont été
ravagées en quelques minutes une nuit
cauchemardesque pour les occupants de
l'établissement ou chez mon ami par
terre pour avoir le plus de
oxygène possible il est vrai que ça
m'est passé par la tête que c'était la
fin
après s'être l'instant tu relis toi
qui cache où vous avez sauté sur le
balcon d'un immeuble raconte je suis
passé sur un parking
quatre clients de l'hôtel ont eu moins
de chance
ils sont morts asphyxiés ou défénestré
12 euros ou pu échapper aux flammes mais
en sautant du troisième étage d'une
personne s'est grièvement blessé
construit en 1950
l'hôtel était équipée d'un seul escalier
sans issue de secours
c'est un hôtel ancien ce qui à l'époque
répondait avec quand il a été construit
répondait à la réglementation en vigueur
un seul escalier est tout à fait
conforme à la réglementation de
réglementation de l'époque aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus le cas ils l'hôtel été
fait aujourd'hui aux nouvelles normes
sus répliquant l' incendie s'est déclaré
dans le hall d'entrée
l'hôtel était essentiellement occupés
par des personnes sdf les chambres
louées par des associations caritatives
quelques heures avant le sinistre devant
l'autel une rixe a éclaté entre deux
concubins placer cet après midi en garde
à vue pour autant la police ce soir ne
privilégie aucune des deux hypothèses
criminelle ou accidentelle
les corps d'un homme et d'une femme ont
été retrouvés et près d'ambronay dans
l'un il pourrait s'agir du couple qui a
disparu au mois de juin en laissant ses
deux enfants domicile familial pour
l'instant les enquêteurs n'excluent
aucune piste
accident suicide ou homicide et puis à
lorient c'est un policier qui était tué
par un forcené alors qu'il tentait de le
ramener à la raison le forcené était
abattu à son tour par des tirs de
riposte des collègues du policier
je vous l'annoncé hier le journal
officiel a publié le montant de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire il est
de 1000 francs 500 francs de moins que
l'an dernier
comment se prépare la rentrée dans ces
conditions dans les magasins caroline
marie et michel giannoulas tous liste en
main ils veulent éviter la cohue des
derniers jours le temps pour eux de
comparer le prix de chaque article d'un
magasin à l'autre
pour beaucoup de parents la rentrée est
un investissement lourd d'autant que
cette année l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire a diminué de 500 francs un
budget restreint donc moins de place
pour les fantaisies pression en classe
primaire ça va faire deux
que fait la personne vont donc c'est
vrai que ça va faire main sur le budget
mais bon il faudra quand même fournir
tout le matériel on essaiera de tout ce
qui est un peu moins cher ce qui pour
les enfants âgés de 6 à 18 ans
l'allocation sera donc de 1000 francs
mille francs c'est peu quand on a une
fille qui rentre en première pour les
livres d'ailleurs à peu près 1000 francs
en ligne de livres encore en les prenant
peut-être
l'occasion donc après la suite il y a
les stylos les cahiers les calculatrices
et les prix ont légèrement augmenté + 3
à 4 cents en moyenne
sans compter qu'il est parfois difficile
pour les parents de résister au dernier
des gadgets à la mode
ce qui est important c'est qu'elles
qu'elles puissent écrire ou avec un
stylo etc
ça lui fait plaisir qui a tiqué d'accous
14 millions d'écoliers de lycéens et
d'étudiants feront dans quelques jours
quelques semaines leur rentrée
dépenseront t'il plus ou moins que
l'année dernière
ce sera un bon test sur le niveau de la
consommation en france
les chaussures bally s'apprêterait à
déposer leur bilan c'est ce que révèlent
les syndicats 1400 personnes seraient
concernées
l'information pour l'instant n'est pas
encore confirmée par la direction du
groupe mélanie mango pour les employés
des usines ben ali la rentrée est plutôt
amer étranglé par la concurrence
italienne et la chute des ventes le
chausseur français serait contraint de
déposer le bilan
motif le groupe suisse qui dirige
l'entreprise ne peut plus supporter les
pertes de sa filiale
les usines de moulins villeurbanne et
vierzon ainsi que le siège parisien de
ben ali risque la fermeture et bien sûr
les 100 magasins répartis dans toute la
france pourrait aussi mettre la clé sous
la porte
au total ce sont mille quatre cent
cinquante salariés qui sont menacés de
licenciement
un emplois sacrifiés chez ben ali
aujourd'hui va coûter plus de 150 mille
francs à la collectivité je veux dire il
faut faire le choix entre garder un
emploi productif et avoir 200 vaches on
n'a plus à villeurbanne donc ce choix là
il incombe y compris aux pouvoirs
publics des pouvoirs publics que les
syndicats de l'entreprise avaient
interpellé en avril dernier
à l'époque la direction menaçait de
fermer l'usiné de villeurbanne
aujourd'hui c'est la totalité des sites
français de ben ali qui est concerné le
tribunal de commerce de paris devrait
rapidement désigner un administrateur
judiciaire
un plan de sauvetage est envisageable
mais pour l'instant aucun repreneur ne
s'est manifesté dans le groupe pechiney
c'est un plan d'économies prévoyant deux
à trois mille suppressions d'emplois qui
devrait être présenté fin septembre
selon la direction il ne devrait pas y
avoir de licenciements secs
et puis sachez que la ratp lance un
emprunt obligataire d'un milliard de
francs un emprunt d'une durée de 11 ans
à 6 40% à souscrire auprès du crédit
lyonnais
5000 enfants de la région parisienne ont
passé la journée sur la plage de cabourg
une journée organisée par le secours
populaire français à ses enfants de 6 à
12 ans venait des quartiers défavorisés
d'île de france ils ont été accueillis
par une fanfare des clowns et ils ont
même reçu chacun un canotier une forme
de clin d'oeil au soixantième
anniversaire des congés payés nous
continuons notre tour de france des
vacances à l'heure du bilan touristique
en languedoc roussillon la saison est
jugée moyenne par les professionnels
pourtant si l'on s'en réfère à certaines
méthodes de comptage très particulière
il semble bien que les vacanciers soit
venu aussi nombreux que les années
précédentes enquêtes de léo lamberton et
pascal pons ciel grisâtre et moral en
berne
fin juillet les professionnels du
tourisme était inquiet les vacanciers
auraient boudé les plages du languedoc
roussillon en partie à cause du mauvais
temps
un mois plus tard pour certains
l'inquiétude est devenu catastrophisme
puisque 95 géré par rapport à 95 -30%
encore
ça d'année en année ça ça arrive s est
pourtant tous les indicateurs ne sont
pas au rouge à portiragnes dans
l'hérault les éboueurs travail tôt tant
que l'an dernier et ils ont fort à faire
pour ramasser les ordures laissées par
les amis vacanciers qui séjournent dans
la station balnéaire
la tournée terminée chaque camion pèsent
les ordures qu'il a collectées la pesée
permettait la commune de calculer les
redevances qu'elle va verser à l' usine
de traitement des déchets les à
portiragnes on a très vite compris que
les ordures peuvent révéler quelques
secrets
en principe un temps estival ils ont
fait des hommes une entre 700 et 750 g
jour d'ordures ménagères
je parlerais steven le sédentaire lui
arrive à une kg alors disons avec le
tonnage la rive les jeunes à faire à peu
près il donne l'estimation de la
fréquentation des gens de la station
chaque jour roger roulier pointe le
tonnage des ordures ménagères et il
compare à 1995
le résultat est net avec près de 400
tonnes collectées en juillet et haute en
août
il ya eu plus de monde cette saison que
l'année dernière minute de ces éléments
le maire de portiragnes ne comprends pas
ceux qui se plaignent d'une baisse de la
fréquentation
il ya peut-être comme fusion entre
fréquentation ou qui traduit le nombre
des syriens qui assure la station et
puis le chiffre d'affaires les
commerçants qui peut effectivement être
une diminution et notamment un début un
début de saison mais les deux choses
sont distinctes
en fait cette année il semble que les
touristes soient venus aussi nombreux
que les années précédentes mais qu'ils
aient dépensé moins
délaissant les bonnes tables pour la
restauration rapide si vous en doutez
les éboueurs de portiragnes pourront
vous le confirmer
depuis un an la chance du médicament
surveille très étroitement un produit
contre l'acné le roaccutane il est très
efficace contre l'acné mais a des effets
secondaires importants notamment pour
les femmes enceintes et explications de
valérie gager et gilles de blair dans la
guerre des boutons les armes sont
légions pommade et savent anti acnéique
se bousculent sur les rayons des
pharmacies mais en 84 un médicament à
révolutionner ce marché déjà florissant
l'euro accutane efficace contre l'acné
dont plus de 80% des cas il présente
cependant l'inconvénient mages
or de provoquer des malformations du
foetus pour les femmes la contraception
est donc obligatoire avant pendant et
jusqu'à un mois après l'arrêt du
traitement
les femmes qui tombent enceintes sont
obligées d'avorter mais malgré
l'information des accidents arrivent
ce sont soit des jeunes des hommes
jeunes adolescents qui ont vu leur
procès améliorer miraculeusement et qui
en ont donné à leurs copines donc la
jeune femme en question n'avait pas vu
le médecin donc pas de dialogue
et deuxièmement c'est en général des
jeunes filles très jeunes pour qui
parler contraception est un peu tabou
notamment en famille en comme
actuellement encore des tas de familles
on peut pas casser en devant la maman
qui vient dans les bureaux parler de ces
choses là et qui en fait ont une vie
déjà sexuelle à l'insu de leurs parents
en france l' agence du médicament a
recensé 3 118 grossesse soro accutane au
cours de ces dix dernières années pour
elle une priorité lutter contre
l'automédication n'est dessus il faut
agir absolument tenir pour éviter que
des femmes se retrouve en possession de
comprimés de rakuten les prennent alors
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'encadrement que ce
soit une information claire des risques
de ce produit est une information de la
manière dont le traitement doit être
conduit déjà sévère le contrôle des
prescriptions de roaccutane va être
renforcé à l'avenir les médecins seront
sans doute obligés de faire pratiquer à
leurs patientes un test de grossesse
chaque mois pendant toute la durée du
traitement dans l' affaire du sang
contaminé
la cour de justice de la république a
terminé son instruction dans cette
affaire laurent fabius edmond hervé et
georgina dufoix ont été mis en examen
pour complicité d'empoisonnement à la
fin du mois de septembre 94 à l'étranger
seize personnes ont été blessées dans
l'accident d'un boeing 707 de la
compagnie egyptair l'avion atterrisse et
à istanbul quand il a quitté la piste
ont pris feu il y avait 120 passagers à
bord et 11 membres d'équipage et le taxi
dans lequel est rentré l'avion est bien
le chauffeur de taxi est sorti indemne
en tchétchénie la situation est de plus
en plus confuse de generali et bed est à
nouveau sur place pour tenter d'éviter
l'assaut des troupes russes sur grossemy
il devrait rencontrer des dirigeants
tchétchènes eric lemasson
elle n'en finit plus de s'étendre la
colonne de l'exode depuis hier le long
de cette route
des milliers de civils tchétchènes 3,7 à
la sortie de grosses ni des soldats
russes qui eux ne savent pas s'ils
recevront l'ordre d'y entrer hier leur
général sur le terrain avait annoncé
haut et fort l'imminence d'une vaste
offensive russe est donné 48 heures aux
civils pour quitter la ville
mais voilà qu'aujourd'hui ce
va-t-en-guerre a été publiquement invité
à rentrer dans le rang
comme l'a expliqué ici le ministre russe
de la défense
ce n'était qu'une initiative personnelle
impossible pour autant de définir les
intentions russes car à moscou deux
camps s'affrontent chaque jour qui passe
donnant l'avantagé à l'un puis à l'autre
l'ex général lié bed charger
personnellement du dossier par eltsine
n'a pas dit son dernier mot il
retournait de toute urgence en
tchétchénie et à son arrivée cet après
midi son premier objectif était de
stopper l'emballement de la machine
militaire russe liebert aura fort à
faire car les partisans de la manière
forte s'appuie sur des décrets
authentique ou non c'est la question
signé de la main même de yalcin mais au
fait que fait boris eltsine
officiellement il se repose à 300 km de
moscou
officieusement la rumeur enfle sur son
état de santé et son incapacité à
diriger le pays
sa dernière apparition publique la voici
c'était le 9 août dernier lors de sa
prestation de serment
en attendant cet arbitrage qui ne vient
pas les civils tchétchènes continuent de
fuir grosse ni car les premiers
bombardements russes ont commencé de
membres de l'organisation humanitaire
action contre la faim ont levé en
tchétchénie lie à 26 jours viennent
d'être libéré il s'agit d'un français
frédéric mallardo et d'un britannique
aux états unis l'armée a été appelée en
renfort pour lutter contre ces incendies
qui ravagent les états de l'ouest 34
foyers d'incendié ont été recensés dans
neuf états américains
vingt mille pompiers cent cinquante
trois hélicoptères une trentaine de
canadair lutte en ce moment contre ces
feux on estime que 200 mille hectares
ont déjà été détruits en football
maintenant les bretons de guingamp iront
en coupe d'europe grâce à leur victoire
contre volvo grave ils se sont qualifiés
pour la coupe de l'uefa laurence rigoler
par quel phénomène une petite commune
apparemment calme paisible se
transforme-t-elle en ville sauvage
certains soirs oui un phénomène qui se
produit souvent à guingamp la maladie du
ballon rond a encore frappé à guingamp
il ya neuf mille habitants il y un stade
de 16 mille places sans compter quelques
balcon où on a une vue imprenable fait
le con toute la ville et même plus m
donc le foot je trouve qu'ils ont tous
bien joué le match je ne suis pas
chauvine je trouve quelqu'un qu'en fait
ils viennent en tout cas de se qualifier
pour la coupe de l'uefa 1 0 face aux
russes de volgograd et voilà comment un
club français sans aucun palmarès
s'offrent l'europe guingamp paix ils
peuvent être fiers de l'être
il ya trois ans il jouait en national 1
il ya deux ans des deux aujourd'hui les
voilà solidement installée au sommet du
foot français
dans les côtes d'armor guingamp à la
côte d'amour fait construire on s'est
pas seulement le week-end que pour les
soirs comme ça c'est toute la semaine on
prépare des trucs on voit ce qu'on va
faire
donc on se perd 3 et franche est pour
nous un budget de 45 millions de francs
c'est un des plus petits de division 1
mais l'ancien club du président de la
ligue noël le graet est aussi l'un des
mieux gérées paraît-il bref l'en-avant
guingamp porte bien son nom
le club a maintenant valeur d'exemple
dans un milieu où l'on est habitué à
jongler avec les artifices de la
réussite
la course en solitaire du figaro
troisième étape
michel desjoyeaux a passé en tête la
première bouée au large de saint nazaire
les 39 concours ont rendez-vous à gijon
en espagne
si le vent le veut bien où les premiers
devraient arriver aux alentours de
vendredi
tous ses concurrents qui donc manquer
terriblement devant ce matin au départ
de saint nazaire
trois cent baleines visiblement égaré se
sont échoués en australie heureusement
la plupart ont pu être sauvés par des
volontaires après des heures d'efforts
josé blanc la pierre dans la nuit
glaciale de l'hiver australien ils ont
quitté leur lit pour courir vers la
plage alerté par des cris de détresse
parce qu'une des étais moi mais ils sont
arrivés trop tard pour certains
mammifères déchiquetés par les rochers
quatorze de ces gros dauphins n'ont pu
être secourus que s'est il passé dans la
tête de ces trois cent baleines qui ont
brusquement pris la direction de la côte
on parle de suicide collectif autre
version plus plausible le troupeau se
seraient égarés de sa route migratoire
il aurait suivi un chef malade
désorienté incapable de maintenir le cap
pendant 24 heures avec les moyens du
bord
secouriste et volontaires ont improvisé
des méthodes de sauvetage pour
rassembler les baleines déboussoler les
remettre dans le droit chemin
ce phénomène s'est déjà produit en
australie en nouvelle zélande
il reste inexpliqué et à juin à juan les
pins c'est une tortue de 27 kg que l'on
a retrouvée épuisé sur une plage elle a
été conduite au service des urgences de
l'hôpital où on a été un peu surpris et
où l'on s'est rendu compte qu'elle avait
avalé une ligne de fond avec beaucoup
d'âmes sont elles étaient en observation
dans un zoo est maintenant à un voyage à
travers le temps grâce à un petit train
à vapeur du début du siècle une balade
le long du rhin dans la campagne
alsacienne pour des touristes
nostalgique
ludovic fossard et sylvain gauthier ce
jour là même les horloges semblait se
tourner vers hier
les yeux des hommes étaient pas en noir
de charbon car ces combattants du temps
qui passe
empêcher que ne se leurre le souvenir de
ces machines à traverser le monde en se
riant des lieux voici aurait pu refermer
les parfaire s'il vous plaît attention
départ c'était en 1900 et des poussières
la vapeur les banquettes en bois les
odeurs de charbon et les remous tout du
long
le train qui fait tilt
et voilà une locomotive 100% alsacienne
vieille de 96 ans qui roule encore une
locomotive vous le devinez
très remontés les vieux souvenirs
c'était notre jeunesse alors c'est pour
bagdad agréable de retrouver un petit
peu cette atmosphère d'antan celle que
la rigolote parce que
harry wagons complets de jeunes on sait
qu'une seule un peu de charbon en 10
d'énergie un peu tu mets et c'est parti
60 kilomètres heure à cette vitesse le
temps prend son temps et à cette époque
le tgv c'était pas pour deux circule
manouche man faire en france avec notre
tgv on pu battre des records au mondial
de vitesse c'est grâce à tous ces
anciens qui ont travaillé avec beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de coeur beaucoup de
sueur souvent pour ne pas dire grand
chose c'est à nous les jeunes ou les
moins jeunes
je gardais ça et de sauvegarder ses
pièces pour montrer à notre génération
ce savoir-faire de nos anciens et voilà
ce que ça donne une 0 30 db 130 des
centaines d'heures de réparation mais le
savoir-faire des anciens est désormais
rajoute une pièce de musée pour un
voyage dans une machine extrêmement rare
alors c'est forcément été merveilleux il
faut dire qu'un train qui chante dans la
campagne
c'est tellement bon qu'on regretterait
presque le temps où la vapeur n'était
pas destiné qu'à la cuisine voilà
nostalgie toujours avec une re
construction à l'ombre du globe theater
une réplique à l'identique du théâtre où
furent jouées pour la première fois les
pièces de william shakespeare
manque de chance l'acteur principal
s'est cassé la jambe brièvement sur les
docks de londres
reconstruit à l'identique le théâtre du
globe dans lequel shakespeare à jouer
2598 1613 reconstruit exactement à
l'identique en roue en bois passé de
soum et ouvert sur le ciel là
aristocrate émanant se tenaient côte à
côte de blues au parterre pour se
régaler des textes de l'auteur le plus
original de son temps voilà 25 ans que
les shakespearien se battent pour avoir
cette merveille qui a coûté la bagatelle
de 250 millions de francs
shakespeare doit être content me direz
vous pas sûr qu'ils ne soient pas
écroulé de rire
jugez plutôt en angleterre on ne dit pas
bonne chance à un comédien qui va
commencer une caisse mais vrai que lègue
à une jambe
c'est ce qu'a fait hier soir l'acteur
principal de la pièce qu'il va débuter
sur toi au globe
on a cherché toute la journée un
remplaçant espérons qu'à celui là on a
dit bonne chance
c'est moins risqué voit la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi dans un
instant la météo de laurent romejko le
dernier journal avec la ravissante
florence dauchez ce sera vers zéro et
redit c'est demain dans les 4 vérités
gérard leclerc sera patrick stefanini le
secrétaire général adjoint du rpr à 13h
vous retrouverez la non moins ravissante
laurence piquet je veux je vous
retrouverai quant à moi à 20h bonne
soirée sur france 2
là